here we go three two one action
hi everybody I'm seat Mart be sure to
watch this year's Oscars big stars big
movies I can't wait that was so cute
good try the Oscars live Sunday March 7
we hold whatever I'm hearing this paper
crackling over here step away from pain
I love live this Sunday on ABC celebrate
the biggest entertainment event of the
year with two incredible hosts hi I'm
Alec Baldwin I'm Steve Martin hi I'm
Steve Martin still rolling
hi I'm Steve Marvin this is Alec Bonin
do another one ready I'm Steve Martin hi
I'm Steve Martin Steve Martin
hey mmm snuggle up to me here buddy
yes darling hi I'm Allie ball wrap it up
be sure to watch this year's Oscars big
stars big movies I can't wait with me
Alec bald and me Steve Martin let's do
it in the lab a better idea if you're
gonna go yes and let's play like that
ready here we go okay we're ready
you've never seen Oscar like this Steve
Martin and Alec Baldwin hosts the
Academy Awards live this Sunday on ABC
I like that